hello everyone i have some news before
we get into this episode which is
honestly almost entirely about the boys
season three no spoilers but very proud
of how much we stayed on track
play watch listen has been running for
almost three years now and the whole
time we have been completely nonprofit
and um sponsor free any money that the
show makes on youtube has gone towards
merch or the animations that i've made
order paying the editor i think i'm
actually backwards in terms of money and
also hosting and all that um and that's
fine that is not going to change we are
not going to change the show and start
doing sponsored ad reads or anything
like that despite getting offered
honestly every week we will not be doing
that however
we did want to start doing some more
creative stuff if possible i'm going to
start small with that and it would be
more of the animated shorts animated by
matt ringstad we've done two so far but
i'd love to ramp it up to maybe do one a
month even the audience seems to really
like them we really enjoy them and if i
can spend money to help an animated or
an artist that seems like a great way to
spend money um so that's the goal but we
also you know have toyed with doing some
more creative stuff on the show before
things like game jams potentially maybe
we make a game some kind of narrative
stuff that we'd have loose conversations
about we would like to take the group
and do some things that are a little bit
bigger i don't want to promise anything
just yet but that is the goal and i
figured because of the way that play
watch listen operates a great way to
offer that would be through patreon what
that means is actually nothing is going
to change you will get a mention of
patreon at the start of episodes and
we'll put some names on screen to thank
people at the end of episodes
but the show is not going to be
sponsored
ad
stuff is not going to happen none of
that um people on patreon will get the
show early and technically youtube ad
free
but that's it the show is going to
remain the same the idea is just that if
the community
wants to support playwatch listen
they can do that and we can respond to
the amount of community feedback there
is on that and then make more creative
stuff so if you would like to support
play watch listen on patreon i'll leave
a link in the description to where you
can do that any amount of money helps
obviously and it is completely not
profit nobody's getting paid all money
would go towards creating more merch
because we don't have a ton and maybe
putting it on a different website a more
effective website than red bull
to more of the animated uh versions of
the show and to potentially some more
creative projects for a very long time i
wanted to have an excuse to get the boys
together to actually do like a live
stream together or something like that
so
that's it basically um if you want to
help out you can if not nothing should
change for you at all but it seems like
a great way for us to be able to do this
without having to put any sponsored ad
reads or whatever into the podcast
um so we can keep it the way that it is
never have to worry about pleasing
anybody
except i guess patreon supporters um i
will also
leave an opportunity for people to ask
questions on patreon for episodes as
well which is not something that we uh
usually do otherwise so
i'm very excited about it i'm excited
about the potential to to make more
stuff i love it being community funded
because it feels like the community is
making more stuff uh but of course
absolutely no pressure you will lose
absolutely nothing if you don't sign up
to the patreon
um but if you do thank you we appreciate
you let's make some cool stuff
and now to the episode
do you what did you have like guests is
your mom in town or something what's
going on
austin wintory
based on what
your [ __ ] your your
your office is like
not into shambles
um
yeah i guess it's also plain overheads
from the sounds of it i think that's
like a lawn mower or something
okay yeah that's tony outside doing his
[ __ ] yeah that you're you are in a tidy
space
i've got like a bag and open an empty
like
thrown aside next to me but you have
like a pristine situation darling i i i
had um
some meetings here a few weeks ago yeah
exactly i had some meetings with my
parole officer and i
wanted to make a good impression so now
i press record on my audio
good me too
uh yeah no content guys we're in that
boys episode guys get ready
yeah theoretically
we talk about the boys
oh man i haven't started yet i'm saving
that for a plane
i just we're already on a tangent i
started because of my dear friend austin
i started
the offer and finished it summarily
within a matter of three days yeah you
watched it
is that the godfather one yes i've been
meaning to get to it yeah i've not
signed it yet it's good yeah mean mean
do now
yeah
they didn't get anything for the
nominations did it
uh
you're right i didn't i stopped reading
once loved and robots got nominated
again
not my episode by the way dude your
episode didn't
jabarro hey how's the finch taking it
he's crying yeah no you asked him david
in the shower keep him uh keep him busy
there
i uh you know if you haven't watched i
mean i think our episode was was
all of them are great i think our
episode was incredible um
if i was on a committee and needed to
nominate one episode from that season
jabarro to me is is the standout one
that best represents everything that i
think tim miller and the show runners
are our adventure trying to accomplish
which is how can we most beautifully and
poetically tell a story within this
medium
and it does that
um it just does it in such a way that it
shows it's not about dialogue it's not
about sometimes it is
but there's there's just so much that
can be
said without a single word spoken
and it does a great job of of doing that
especially when that's baked into the
conceit
um you haven't watched it you should
it's so good just watched it again the
other night and um
it's um there's just so much i i agree i
bad traveling is amazing
but um
jabarro is one of those where it's
what's so great about it
is it
it's something that could probably only
exist in that format it probably only
makes sense as an episode of love death
robots like you wouldn't want a feature
version of that i think you wouldn't
want no a
live action version of that like
it's all the thing
it's it's nestled perfectly into the
medium that it was
created for intended for yeah yeah and i
think no the story was not intended for
that that's what's so fascinating to me
it's it's all adapted material
so
i i would just comes together so
incredibly
yeah i i really want to go back and read
the um all the source material for
everything that he finds or whether it
be short stories or or whatever or just
uh it's inspiring to go back and
to read uh bad traveling included that
one i could see as a feature as like a
kind of cool monster meets mastering
commander
uh there's so much that we will show up
horrors but very very serious yeah yeah
it could be really cool we'll get into
that but i think i think the thing that
puts it put it say uh the tension is is
the relationship with the crew and i
think establishing our like we never
shot with our captain our captain was
just kind of like a
she's there for one line you know yeah
but establishing
how the crew comes together who the crew
is you could go in and just have
episodes about each one because they're
all incredibly um dense characters that
you get to see just just a little bit of
um
and then of course finding out more
about my character yes indeed but um
the offer man
mike i just it's so valid
yeah i think now it's on netflix check
check in the uk because i think it may
be on netflix now uh where you guys are
but uh the one of your countrymen um
matthew good
just [ __ ] slays he's one matthew
he's in the shower
um he does so still get is bob evans i
can't believe it babe he just does an
incredible job
everything he wants to do i mean he is
just crushing it as bob evans if you've
never seen
the kid stays in the picture um and i
would i would highly recommend watching
it rather than reading the book
um
there's an audiobook isn't there that
he recorded
well he did the he did he did the
narration for the movie as well but i
thought that that was actually just that
was not recorded for the movie i thought
that was extracted from the audiobook
that's going to audible.com
that's very impossible the book is far
more exhaustive
because i decide on the um marcus
aurelius that you recommended oh you
know what i should be getting
there's um i gotta show you this too if
i can reach it
stays in the picture
can i plug my buddy's book
do it
so
donald robertson who wrote uh how to
think like a roman emperor which was
recommended to me by uh my buddy
jacksepticeye
um and i s
plowed through his book i did the
audiobook i started reading and then i
actually switched to the audiobooks i
wanted to hear from him and he's got
this lovely just scottish brogue accent
that just everything he says has more
weight to it somehow
but he um he and i kind of developed a
bit of a friendship and
he said i'm thinking about doing a
graphic novel like let's go what's it
about he's like i want to do the story
marcus aurelius as a graphic novel and
so he
over like four years
he got this portuguese artist zendugo
fraga that's long that's a that's a
that's a that's a tome right there it is
not small and it's like i didn't realize
that was a graphic novel when you held
it up that's quite something yeah it's
it's it's amazing dude um
and it tells the story of marcus
aurelius in a very very unique
interesting way and it makes it so much
more
he contextualizes everything so it's not
just like
oh i'm just you know pontificating and
spouting off philosophy but it's like
i'm sitting here on the banks of the
river as i just watched ten thousand of
my men die and these are the thoughts
that i have and so it paints that
picture so it's really also he often is
he often is cast as the secondary
character to his son as well right a lot
of retellings of that story yeah like so
it's
you know
it's cool to see him as like a main
character he communist is the more
interesting dramatic
character yeah because everybody wants
to watch him fail but i mean marcus
aurelius is the one where everyone wept
for days after he died he's just like oh
he's so cool so yeah varesimus is the
name of it and um he's so worthy of all
adulation and and uh and purchase the
art is really really cool
nice
well i
one of the things that i
love about the offer has been that at
the end i've watched nine of the ten um
and um
and actually funny enough last night i
got to the end of nine and i thought the
series was over it was actually it was
such a poetic
place to end
that i thought
that could be that could i said i'm
pretty certain there are ten
but that felt like the end in a in a
very
interesting even though you know that
there's more story to tell like if
like you know that
you know just from a sheer historical
standpoint that they're not to the end
of the the story it's still scary so 10
being a prologue or an epilogue rather i
could see that
but yeah it's so
i um
i've really really fallen in love with
it it was one of those that i first
heard about it because
a handful of friends of mine have like
little bit parts through it so i kept
hearing about it through the lens of
like oh i'm in town shooting i have a
day in town shooting on this thing the
offer i kept hearing about it and i and
i it was always just the offer the offer
the offer and then at some point someone
said you know the godfather show and i
thought is that what is that what that
is that feels like
that i had a very different thing in my
head this whole time
and um and i remember a friend of mine i
asked him
so how did like he had they went to the
premiere you know whenever it first came
out
they screened i guess the first episode
or whatever and
i said so what uh what's your take you
think it's going to go over well and it
goes i bet critics are going to look
down on it as very kind of poppy
but audiences are going to love it
and zombie
i don't remember if that's the word he
used but like it's like a very
rose-colored lens it lens uh like it
it's not there's not it's not like this
gritty
you know
nail like dirt under the fingernails
kind of show everything has a little bit
of a sheen to it even at its most
um that's a bit like um get shorty which
was also excellent kind of that slightly
come like goes down yeah like a nice
easy kind of show get shorty that the
conceit of that is a little bit more
kind of like it's a true story but it's
like get this
what happens when this guy tries to make
a film but i i i still think there was a
lot of grit i i would say that to every
what whatever first of all it's a very
approachable story you don't need to
know anything about the godfather if you
do it hits on a totally other level
right um to where you can appreciate
you're like holy [ __ ] i know it's scene
they're shooting and when they you know
they pan out and they show the why
you're like i know what location you're
on well and to that end one little
detail that i so love is that they've
got all these actors
who are having to play these iconic
like pacino brando pacino yeah so it's
actually about the productions i assumed
it was about like the pre-production
kind of there's actually they're
actually like showing the making money
it's ten hours it's ten hours so it
starts with the novel and it from the
concept to filming and it's all the way
through
oh yeah and it's self-contained so it's
not it's gonna be season two then i
guess it's not it's
at this point honestly that makes me
more likely to watch a tv show if i know
there's a finite end yeah preach i'm the
same exact way as like i don't know if i
can invest eight years of my life into
something yeah it gets good in season
three oh yeah
but what does it say because the show is
um
because the show is like they've got you
know all these real people and like such
good casting for capturing these real
people of coppola and
and it just goes on and on and on dan
fulger as coppola is amazing
i found out i was like i think i had his
number at one point and so i texted him
i was like i'm [ __ ] gobsmacked at
your performance dude it is
transformative he is not doing a bit he
just copolis shines through and he
he is
standout character standout character
among many that's the thing that's so
remarkable about it is there's a lot of
real highlights and the fact that all
these are real people
um and there's a real burden to try to
capture them faithfully i really love
copela's vibe
on the show how he's
he's very kind of
annoying he's got a little bit of a
spoiled child aspect of like i want my
movie this way this is and if they're
like well you're gonna have to
compromise on this one little thing and
he's like no
that's but
he's also genuinely he doesn't come
across like this curmudgeon or anything
he comes across as like
genuinely so excited and passionate and
when they see like a location for the
first time and he goes oh my god what if
we did this and went to this and you see
that i i get such a contact high from
people that are that jazzed about what
they're doing and about the industry
they work in and all that kind of stuff
it to me it's it's it's it's just a wash
in
that passion
and um the kind of
another aspect that i that i really
really love is the um the fact that
they're shooting the godfather and they
have all these actors portraying these
iconic
actors
but because they there's like only so
far they're willing to kind of create an
alternate universe
um they're they're making they're not
making the show's version of the
godfather they're making the godfather
we've seen which means that one of the
tricks they do that i love is every time
they're like watching the scene or
watching all you see is the reaction of
the crew you never show
like
this is the delivery
famously yeah there's no reenactments of
the movie itself i love that that's a
small way of doing that
my favorite one by the way this is not a
spoiler if you've seen godfather you see
it is the scene where they beat up carlo
that
he died like he died i i saw the
notification of his death like like an
hour after watching that episode
really um it was yeah it was i mean the
next morning or whatever that was a good
day
yeah
um
it's what's fascinating to me is is
learn i love learning about the industry
in which i work right
so
to realize that there was a time when
coppola's name was a blemish upon your
project and not a bolster
to to realize that jimmy khan was the
one that had the real star value
not duvall
certainly not pacino and brando i've
heard this story from coppola's mouth
about brando having to put up a million
dollar bond
um he had to work for scale
and uh he had to audition
so
there's there's a lot of different
different versions of same stories that
i've heard and like the the
dramatization of those moments was
really really cool but to anybody who
wants to
to to operate in this industry on any
level any level because it talks about
the crew producers the writers the
actors
everybody it should be kid stays in the
picture i've talked about this one
before should be required reading
viewing or listening play watch or
listen
play the kid stays in the picture play
this stage in the picture
um in this movie as well it's just to
remember that
man
it's so the tension exists only because
we know that the godfather is arguably
the greatest movie of all time if not
one of
um
the to realize that there was a time
when they had to sell that notion
and how many opportunities there are
right up until it was picture locked i
mean they were like they were that that
sorry to just jump in on the point
you're making but i i feel so strongly
the same way about it that anybody
there's this perception i think uh that
filmmaking
is you know
very glamorous and very and very you
know kind of posh and that there's a
very
there's a very kind of um
i don't know if easy's the right word
but it's like of all the things even
people in the industry will go
you know like who am i to complain you
know some people have real problems or
some people have real jobs and that kind
of thing and what i love about this show
and there's a obviously there's a
there's an aspect of that that i fully
agree with i mean it's not the same as
you know working in a coal mine and no
one would dispute that
but one of the things that i love is
that the show does such a good job
because the whole thing
is done through the eyes of already the
the producer who gets this thing off the
ground
and
it just makes you realize that even for
a movie that turns out as one of the
greatest ever made
all movies it's by the skin of their
teeth and that every single day there's
ten thousand fires that have to be put
out and it's basically a continuous
nightmare and when you in the movie in
this show does such a good job at
showing
just like the comedy of errors that is
all filmmaking and game design and
television production and
you know season two of the offer should
probably be about the making of the
offer where you realize they probably
had all the same [ __ ] all the same
problems challenges and everything just
to make this show about the godfather by
the skin of their teeth and no one knows
you're building the road as you're
driving at a breakneck speeds down it
you know that
yeah well totally we work backwards
right in terms of our assumptions we
always assume it's exactly what we're
saying we always assume that oh the
godfather was obviously objectively
brilliant therefore everyone along the
process must have known and everyone
knows about the resources yeah it's and
it's true of games as well as there was
a i can't remember if it was i remember
it was a joke i was hearing in private
or if it was something around twitter
but like um this idea that like
most great game design happens in the
two weeks you're planning your gdc talk
because effectively
you you do the thing it goes well guys i
think i just figured out what game we're
making
it's that though right like there is
those and there are those moments of
epiphany when you're making anything and
we're we're we're on the thing we're
working on the moment we're have we're
starting to hit that phase where we're
starting to have these moments of like
oh that's going to look really clever
like the thing we just did by accident
the thing that is an outcome of
pragmatism and luck basically is like oh
that's that almost looks like an adult
thought it through before we started
that's amazing and you and you kind of
stack enough of those up and you've got
a video game right so yeah i don't want
to miss quote i don't want to miss quote
amy but we were at dice one year and
she said something to the effect of
i don't think there's ever been anyone
that has ever shipped a game that they
were happy with
it's always broken right up to two
points people who make bad doors people
who make bad games are often very proud
of them i've found
all right we [ __ ] did it guys we just
we're great we're just
domain nailed it
binary domain was a [ __ ] classic and
you need to show no no no it's not it is
not a classic try to find it right now i
dare you they burn the copies
there's many classics that are hard to
get hold on they destroyed
the only person i can think of whoever
was like my game is amazing and then i
play it i'm like honestly it actually is
pretty amazing is joseph ferris
and which one
it takes two or
more well actually i guess you're right
i guess his his big moment was for a way
out i think um that's his name
right like i don't think his first one i
mean like a way out was not the big one
it was definitely it takes two a way out
was just like no but i'm saying the one
that he gave the big speech about how
it's the most brilliant game ever was i
think
it was the way out one i was on keely's
thing right yeah yeah you're right
yeah [ __ ] the oscars i was that was that
was quite a quite a moment
but hey man way to make yourself an
iconoclast and way to make yourself a
there we go
i don't think there's anything wrong
just press record
i don't think there's anything wrong
with with uh
quick put the video on put the video on
quick yeah yeah excellent video
recording video no we did it we did we
did it
just let me press record on the audio
real quick actually you know what's so
funny there was no phantom power going
to my mic for the first maybe 10 minutes
so you got zoom audio for the first few
minutes and i just an empty
audio file until i realized oh [ __ ] and
i clicked on my link it happens it's all
right
no it doesn't i am always perfect i
think this is this show is too popular
for us to continue to make these kind of
let's bring you up to speed real quick
um
alana anybody
hey yup what's up
david fincher's in the shower okay with
with um
uh [ __ ] who was he in there with matthew
good matthew good
um
and who i did not know was british until
i watched the behind the scenes
yesterday of course everybody says yeah
well because yeah he's putting on such a
he's putting on such a
a voice that i i had no
um
it just didn't it just some of the best
american actors are british like that's
that's been my australian 100
homelander dudes australian new zealand
someone corrected me on that earlier
very very sternly new zealand he's a new
zealander apparently i don't know if
that's true he's terrible there's one on
here
what's happening
i look like
they're the the remnants of the play-doh
that someone just squeezed out for
something you know
you look rough troy you look right right
a little bit yeah
that means i'm working for something i
did spray you look like you got a
blowout
i just for some reason have bits that
are just sort of
you know
what the [ __ ] is this i don't know
me and austere here like yeah yeah i
also care about my hair i got a
different haircut for the first time in
20 years and i don't know what i'm
supposed to do with it uh did you it's
just short
that one right there right
that hair got short yep
anyway david was in the shower
are you up to speed on the boys alana
and mike no and i would love to be i
stopped watching it because um i was
eating
while the episode with the milk thing
happened and then i i didn't want to
watch it because i was eating and then
it just never went back
but i really enjoyed it it's not one to
eat a meal with to be fair right very
rarely as an episode
yeah big mouth is the same way i can't i
can't watch that show while i eat but i
love that show oh yes
yeah it's it's it's um
it's a coming-of-age
sort of metaphors type story
uh where it's about growing up through
this very wildly sort of bizarre lens
and
i think it's at its best it's absolutely
amazing and the clever
characters that they create to represent
the neuroses of young kids like the
hormone monsters and things are
are
truly genius shame demons i'm looking at
some art yeah so there are literally
like monsters in it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like
an imaginary show
of where they're it's kind of like not
the office where everyone's you know
breaking the fourth wall talking to
camera or anything but it's the hormone
all of those hormone monsters at their
place of work
um and so you have
it's more focused on them than it is the
kids
um but i gotcha to their credit the
thing that i love about what they're
doing
they're really having a conversation
about hmm they're really having a
conversation about what kids are dealing
with like there's one episode that's
growing one
um
that
deals with a girl having uh her first
period at the statue of liberty
and
the the way that they're talking about
sexuality i think is incredibly
important oh yeah um and it covers it
hits like seemingly everything there's a
coming out story there's
there's like the kid who's discovering
he's
like he's got his best friend who's just
like pure horn dog absolute like
depraved monster and he doesn't feel
that and he's kind of like is there
something wrong with me that i'm just
not this horny degenerate all the time
and like
it it really because the character cast
is big enough
they explore
just the awkwardness of growing up
so well
but it's an adult show right it's not
funny oh extremely
it's [ __ ] every frame
god damn you [ __ ] already it has some
of the most
sort of vile things i've ever seen
animated in my life it takes south park
and it's like
just wait hold our beer yeah
it's pretty it's but the but the voice
acting nick crawl
um and like there's eight characters i
think yeah the best of which is uh
what's her name
um
you know the one that's like how dare
you
um oh
this is why it's all characters that
he's it's using voices of characters
he's done in like his stand-up and stuff
like that's why why am i blind
so funny because there's like he'll do
it it's where it's it's kind of feels
like you know how when you're driving
and you're sort of very gently on the
gas pedal but you kind of shift
positions and you slip and you
accidentally hit it you kind of rev the
car you ever had that experience just
unexpectedly a little burst that's how
she talks so it's like are you walking
to the store drew there's like these
little bursts of loudness randomly that
kills me every time i it's just i feel
like that's gotta be a thing that like
probably rick and morty pioneered in
some way and voice acting of like
i think the premise there is that he's
always drunk right it's it's
he goes in and uh drinks like a gallon
or drinks a liter of coke like he has a
liter of coke with him as he's reporting
justin speech is very
like straight when you meet him outside
of that his his voice is like just very
not monotone but like very sad you
wouldn't know that that was him from
just him it's wild but he also like
i mean you you could tell that that
guy's so much too
yeah
he's got a good oh so brilliant
show us something
but yeah the boys season three
that just wrapped up haven't haven't
even started i'm saving for a plane i
really do it is why this is explained so
the writing got better
that's not saying that someone earlier
the writing got really good this season
and stuff about like
i'm gonna be very vague family just as a
general theme is so well handled across
the show well the way they touch on with
the game everywhere is amazing
yeah even the way they did season two i
was like holy [ __ ] like my boy carl's
great minute they gave us some [ __ ] i
feel like there's not a single weak link
in this season for me it it even the
kind of b story stuff that's not the
focus but it's sort of
it's actually it's actually yeah it's
actually it it doesn't feel b by the end
um you're like well that's the key to a
great b story is that it it rhymes with
it ends up being it's the a of its own b
yeah i i felt like uh i really did like
season one
i've just loved everything i liked i
liked season one but i was worried that
the show
was using
gore and edginess as a crux and then one
feels stupid
it feels like a very teenage
thing a crutch probably um who cares
what words you know who needs something
no that's a very important distinction
like is it using it as like a as a
foundational element of the premise or
is it using it as just a kind of a
no i felt like it was like using it to
to
uh make people pay attention like you
know some writers pure shock value yeah
exactly it feels like a teenager trying
to get attention that first season it's
a shame because i think it grows into
something it grows beyond that for me as
it goes on i think they once they
realize what they're trying to say i
think it gets a lot better i don't
actually fully agree with that to me the
violence always felt
in service of
the message the cavalier
these superheroes there's no
checks and balances for these people
they exist so outside of any of the
normal civilization and they're so
it's so impossible to hold them
accountable
uh you have to see the casual nature
with which they can just absolutely
obliterate life and and not and not give
a [ __ ] and i feel like
well it's also the source material
well yeah that's true but i think people
say i definitely went in assuming it was
going to be hardcore superhero rather
than what i think it is which is like
horror it's a it's horror with it's
satirical horror it's uh it feels like
you know i think it's become that like
from what i can tell about season three
again haven't watched it yet i will
catch up it's that it has it's i mean
season one had that too season one
absolute fear that the characters have
for the heroes for the superhero
characters like that feels like horror
to me that tension you feel
when yeah
yeah it's it's it's that creeping dread
that sense of just how scary it's almost
lovecraftian right like how bad it would
be to be around gods like how dangerous
that would be how's terrifying season
three takes that to such new heights
holy crap that like yeah there are
scenes where there's two characters just
in a room talking and you're like i
can't breathe this is yeah this is just
that's what i'm talking about with the
horror that's why it feels like horror
to me it feels that's how i watch it i i
would say not psychological thriller
segment but not psychological thriller
like you had put it into
the horror category
it was a little potato for me where
would you where would you put science to
the lambs right like i said that earlier
someone like psychological feelings not
a horror so i see i would spray this
yeah
okay
i would say
what the guy doing homeland is doing
that guy is doing
he's the scariest character since
hannibal lecter like 100 and where that
goes as it goes on and how terrifying he
is is just amazing i don't know if i've
seen anything else that really does that
where you're
frequently scared of multiple characters
i have trouble thinking of anything else
that you'd be like oh my god friends
and seinfeld friends terrified of ross
yeah guys unhinged no it's it's
definitely like i liked i liked season
one probably a little bit more than you
did mike but i was worried that the
things that i found um that felt
performatively edgy about it that i
would end up just finding more reading
as the show went on but it seems like
it's only got better i think it grows i
think that stuff i think that stuff
stays about where it is but i think
everything else comes up so much that
it's like there's there's there's
imagery and everyone watching this who's
seen it there's imagery in the first
episode of the third season that will
live with everyone who's seen it for the
rest of their lives it's the most
horrific terror like horrible thing ever
but it's
horrible but it's but it's hilariously
terrible 100 it's that teenage thing of
getting you know look at me look at me
but there's so much other cool stuff
there that for me i can you know i i
still enjoy that that's what i would
think would be an important distinction
of like anything i just put a horrible
image in austin's head and everyone
listening to this i can't stop thinking
about it i'm very curious because then
he laughed too and i'm like damn okay
it's like tarantino you know like
remember in pulp fiction where it's
territory
no but he would like he like he was 100
yeah you know that you remember the
scene in pulp fiction where they're in
the car and they actually shoot the guy
in the back and then the rest
yeah there's like brain in samuel l
jackson's hair that's the rest of that
scene and it's hilarious because it's
just so [ __ ] up
that's so that's where the boys goes
that i find delight that's right that's
what i think keeps it out of horror and
that's why like if you laugh it's not
horror
well there's a lot of very camping
that's interesting yeah i feel like i
mean
but that's that's for totally dead
he was doing that [ __ ] in earnest are
you identifying slasher as being horror
i would say hellraiser is horror serpent
in the rainbow is horror
um what's cabin in the woods i agree
with both of those
horror i would say but it's also joss
whedon doing his thing where he is
intentionally making tropes out of he
he's underscoring the cliches of those
horror things that doesn't make anyone
making that the conceit
huh that doesn't make it not horror i
think that that's just did you laugh
like when he flew into the off the
motorcycle you everybody laughed so i
just don't think it's it's so funny when
i started watching that movie i didn't
know it was joss whedon and i was like
oh i hate these stupid characters
they're so cliche and then i was like oh
it's a perfect way to watch that movie
though that's something
yeah
that was joss wanting to make a movie
with his friends that's that's exactly
what that was it was like i just want to
make a food with friends how can i do
this really cheaply like you could do
a horror movie in a cabin he's like got
it
the um i don't think hor are you
suggesting that
laughing is somehow disqualifying for
the label of horror this is this is 100
of subjective definition based upon
me right but i i would say that the
intention of horror is not to bring
levity but it's to bring
a constant sense of foreboding and fear
or shock or disgust i think
so from my perspective it's okay
about catharsis though right it's also
about surviving it's like a roller
coaster it's surviving fear
but i expect that to often include
joy right like the the other side the
laugh the uncommon the same reason we
laugh when we're uncomfortable that kind
of
release of of awkward tension feels like
part of the horror most horror movies i
feel have a moment where the audience
will laugh
or
enjoy something in that way i think a
lot of like gore for example like the
height and gore is often done
to entertain and to amuse or like
you know get a reaction other than
you're not meant to feel you're not
meant to feel viscerally disgusted at
gore in horror movies for 90 minutes
right yeah you couldn't that would be
you know it's not real right like you
there's a that's the tension that's why
that's why i have so much respect for
people who do horror well i it requires
i can't imagine the level of precision
that's required to create that emotional
space for an audience like exorcist what
would you call that
that's horror that yeah that's got to be
horror quintessential
totally i i think i think i for we
but that's hilarious because she says
your mother sucks cox for help
which is naturally very funny
but
i think that um
i think that
just from my angle at least having
written music for a lot of low budget
horror in my entire life the span of
emotions across just those projects is
so wide that horror
is
is a big tent because you have films
that are
like
silence of the lambs which although i
don't consider that horror to me that's
a drama um and and i don't really know
where the line
falls necessarily in a sort of
scientifically precise way but it
doesn't feel
like it's definitely not horror because
it it won an oscar and you can't win an
oscar if you're a heart oh no he didn't
do that
he ever won an oscar i don't think slams
won the oscar right well i know that the
omen won the oscar for best score so
if you count that
he has never won no one cares about
soundtracks austin i i think
i don't think
i don't think a horror movie's ever won
best picture
i would believe i mean i think was uh
jordan peele won the best screenplay uh
for get out
and get out is brilliant and horror
i still don't know
right still has comedy in there because
this is a good point i think you can
have both i i think it's actually i my
like one of the closest directors i work
with is this guy paul solitt who the
first movie we did together was called
grace
that you know that was a film that
played at sundance we had people faint
at our premiere but the mur there's also
moments in that movie that are
funny
um
and like and it has there's a thing that
he does at the end
i don't even i don't even want to say
what it is because it
it's the only time i've ever seen
somebody get up get a joke out of their
credits um that the audience actually
clocks top to bottom
um
which was great and it's a it was a
perfect way because the movie is so
unnerving
and like i said two people fainted in
earnest and it happened at other
screenings too
but
the very last thing that everybody at
that theater at sundance remembered was
laughing
um
and it was like a relief it was like oh
my god like this is like a weight off
and that was exactly why he did it and
so i think paul the director he would be
the first to say
comedy has always been interwoven with
horror because if you can disarm people
you cannot you can also get them harder
uh if the goal is to shock or if the
goal is to
drive you're on your guard
yeah you're resetting the discomfort
every five minutes it's a resident evil
safe room and then you have the
opportunity to ramp it back up again
which i do think the boys does very well
it's like has moments where you actually
feel safe which i feel like makes the
tense moments more terrifying especially
because that show's not afraid to pull
the rug out at any moment right right
you know
like the way game of thrones started
where where it you
the safe moments were actually falsely
safe yeah because at any moment they
might not be driving down the road going
super fast you will no matter how fast
you're going you eventually will become
normal and you'll feel like you're going
60 miles an hour 40 miles an hour or
whatever might do the conversion for our
that's why troy kills people i think
that's like 10 000
or something yeah sure i got a list of
uh
scary movies that have won
academy awards they're obviously for
different things but it looks like
silent slams did win best picture i've
just received this uh word from my
assistant yeah we have a list
of uh mystery winning thrillers misery
misery mariah yeah
not seen
the thriller
why because she swings an axe that makes
it
does that but does that make uh yes that
means it's a horror movie if it's or if
i save a cake it's horrible what about
oh this is a shot and all that yeah
okay okay troy how about jaws is on the
list how about yours is jaws horror jaws
is light-hearted in a bunch of ways
guys guys that's one of my favorite
lines
that's the most funny movie the most
iconic line from that is a comic relief
line right we're going to need it
is jaws not horror
i think jaws is like quintessential
horror i think jaws shaped horror jaws
invented blockbuster horror basically
jaws is so horrible
the blockbuster period
of my face
get your hand out of my face
let's do that probably it's fine you
have to hold it up close
you hold it up close yeah then my hand
gets focused and my face doesn't correct
it'll fix when you take it away
yeah
focus on your hands and then you pull it
back whatever
jaws troy is it hard solidarity i'm
gonna
yeah i guess i guess jaws would go if
i'm thinking about reminding myself of
the days of walking through blockbuster
what the [ __ ] austin
spotify guys you're missing out
on on austin being blurry yeah yeah
awesome
you want
i don't i sometimes see austin as a
blurry person
and has nothing this this is the
predator
view of me
play watch listen is it horror
mike what the [ __ ] it's just
collapsing into juvenile uh it is hard
we're all pressing all the buttons now
i am actually currently i feel like
whenever i don't have to record the
video i have so much power i'm entering
a a code for a video game to download
right now but nobody knows because you
can't see my screen i can do whatever i
want yeah appreciate you saying uh
engaging the conversation i asked you a
question it's jaws horror i did i would
say that it was i'm i was saying i'm
trying to remember like walking down the
different departments in a blockbuster
right
and like if i was gonna go to jaw go to
jaws hey
greg and he's like hey man i'm looking
for jaws and he'd be like oh you're
going to find that in the what section
tara
horror shocks
no i feel like yeah horror i mean
especially at the time it was so scary
it famously like made people stop
[ __ ] going to the beach for that
summer right so the
talk about scary
um hold on mike's little jump scares
this week
[Laughter]
i think horror
is
probably of all the genres it's one of
the widest
yeah and it has a lot of fields
yeah exactly like there are there are
there are horror films that are pure
camp that are at no point are
they well the scare scream the very
first scream
had its moments of like actual like you
know
you know yeah yeah oh we just are we
just discounting like the kind of the
slasher movie is just not horror is that
what i think slash is horrific for sure
i think slash is a horror for sure yeah
i would
yeah to me that's quintessential horror
it's just light that's the point it's
like a psychological horror is
inherently more
scary like psycho is a vastly scarier
movie to me yeah exactly exactly it's
those things that they they somehow tap
into these kind of
facts about life or about people about
the about human tendencies
just go holy [ __ ] that's
that's i think what makes the boys also
so special is
i think
homelander is so understandable as a
character there's nothing about
why he is the way he is that makes you
feel like that's a leap where'd that
come from i just look at it and i go
everything about that is so
uh like relatable is not the right word
but it's just
it's real it's so yeah you someone human
his damage is human
100
yeah it's really and that to me is just
infinitely scarier
than
the kind of like scheming like
kind of
world domination kind of
or i mean his whole character is like so
hinged on
if anybody will at any point trigger one
of his various insecurities so you're
walking around on a tightrope because
somebody's ego is so fragile and they
are a nuclear weapon at all times
someone like that we totally experience
them 100 and that's so believable that
you're walking around people all the
time such as troy
whose egos are so fragile that they will
just murder you
uh he's killed he'll kill again that's
all i'm saying that's all i'm saying
can't prove that i know it's definitely
like a thing that i think is also made
more scary by the knowledge that if you
were in the situation having a
conversation with him that you could
[ __ ] it up where
your instances in horror that you don't
feel that way i think one that i think
makes
sorry apologies series three
100
does some connective tissue to kind of
directly connect
the way you know real people have
experienced that kind of personality
type every day to the reality like it
goes
it goes for the jugular in terms of like
it removes any vagueness about what
that's referencing or what that's uh you
know a
a uh welcome to the spoiler cast of play
watch listen for the boys
i so want to talk about it but i i i
need you guys to see it in earnest i
need a question i need just a little
while longer i could turn my headphones
off if you want to actually i could just
give out something
specific
this is here's a question since we
haven't actually really talked about
games this episode
how is it not
what else would it be i would say well
okay so retroactively i would say it's a
psychological thriller because it's not
there's one scary scene in it
but it's
it's a payoff of a movie that's eating
away at your defense the tension
is increasing the entire film i feel
like it's a horror you're going to
disagree with the next one probably even
more than black swan
oh yeah i don't consider that a horror i
don't think i do you haven't seen it i
feel like you would love it
it's it's a long story i've never seen
it i had a girlfriend that that was
super weird about
uh that so she no
didn't didn't uh well it might be time
to turn over
yeah i mean trust me i understand that
it's a beautiful film and uh
i i just uh
it's such a good screening i want to see
it it wasn't just a beautiful film it
was a film that captured the
self-destructive nature of artists in a
way that i thought was
better than i'd ever at least at the
time remember feeling i've never seen
that captured
the seductive nature of
your art consuming you to the degree
that you don't even realize how
self-destructive you're being i remember
thinking this movie captured that better
than i had ever like you think of
you know so there's been a lot of great
films about art you know amadeus and
these kind of but this was one or about
it's about the sort of almost like the
toxicity in a way of
the creative impulse
uh
it blew me away i i felt like i haven't
seen it since the time i saw it in the
theater but i remember i also saw it at
the arc light and i remember thinking it
was the loudest i've ever heard a movie
in my life i walked out of that sort of
rattled by the visceral impact of it too
but so i think you're confusing i think
you're confusing the great movie made
about amadeus with beethoven and that
being uh bill and ted's excellent
adventure
um you're right it's not really
that's an action
movie it's an action movie aliens was
nominated for score
james horner had two weeks to run but he
cares
there's someone listening on the show
who cares what's up
during a commercial break nobody cares
it got best visual effects best sound
editing
for aliens
that always happens with those movies
it's always like transformers will get
visual effects and sound design and
it'll make a billion dollars you know
the marvel movies have started to
like you know you saw yeah yeah you saw
like uh black panther was actually
getting wide nominations but typically
the the very like summer mainstream
would always get technical nominations
and yeah nothing else
i mean now they do costume for marvel i
just want this [ __ ] hair i just want
to just what i don't know
anyway the fly
poor
the the cronin with the original one or
jeff goldblum jeff glover
yeah cronenberg one
what that went for like costume or
something
special effects
best makeup yeah yeah yeah
which makes sense yeah makeup yes
costume but i was picturing yeah
you know who scored that movie
no
but still set aside the lack of caring
and indulge in the intellectual
curiosities
same person who scored silence the lambs
and they are very very very very famous
for a score
that is as opposite of those
this was a guy who for 20 years was one
of the most well-known composers in the
world of horror he also did all of
cronenberg's films existance
um um um
uh crash not the
not the like
the drama about interweaving lives or
whatever but the sex we call it the sex
with
car wound car accident wound movie yeah
um
what
don't google it there is two crash
movies it's fine don't worry about it
first one wasn't it with what's her name
uh she has everything she says she talks
like this
i want to have sex in the back of the
car james spader
yeah i think spader is in that i can't
remember 100 i'm worried
people get off no no guess there are
questions that don't need answering how
long i have no idea austin stay away
from beethoven
yes
yes nailed it uh first guess
[Music]
wrap it up oh it's interesting it's
always interesting it's someone who's so
overwhelmingly known for horror but
actually
they're one of the most famous composers
in the world now for something that's as
opposite as that as you can imagine i
always found that wait i got it i got i
got it was it
gonna make new home movie it was never
it was never
gonna do something
tell us
what troy's version could be
howard shore known for the oh no a
different person
yeah he did all that he did the flight
it silenced the land which makes sense
that jackson would hire a horror
composer right that makes sense
actually the reason why was because
howard shore uh
visited the set while they were filming
with an annotated copy of the book and
basically showed that he was singularly
obsessed with lord of the rings and made
it very clear that they were not just
going to get some guy doing a gig but
they were a guy who's prepared to to
give it all because it was also nice
you have my
sword and he did a great job you did a
great job it's beautiful soundtrack yeah
there were there
yeah he won three oscars for
that gig um but the first movie he's
unusually won three scores three oscars
well it's not unusual when you have a
runaway hit to if you write a song which
he wrote songs for all three films and
he won song and score for the third one
and score for the first one and it's
michael bolton also wrote one and it
just never
cutting room floor yeah yeah
i have a habit
and i've got big feet
i'm going to go so far feel like that
take back that ring feels so good i
[ __ ] love it the omen
i already called i already already
called that one out
i apologize lost in my apologies awesome
here's here's another there's a
hilarious thing though
so goldsmith's i've never seen him
goldsmith's theme to the omen is called
ave satani latin for hale satan and it's
a choir literally singing ave satani
it's so good so iconic it's in [ __ ]
south park um and um but the crazy thing
is in a world that i will never
understand this
jerry was nominated and won for best
score
um
but he was also nominated and lost for
best song for the theme ave satani if
you look up best song nominees in 1976
the theme to the omen is one of the
nominees and i've always thought that
was
the weirdest [ __ ] thing
ever technically it's a song because
there's vocals
i guess
it was a very odd
um
this is going to win for best musical or
comedy
you know what i mean like they they yeah
like what was the weird one
was it like since anyway right yeah it
was like
dallas buyer's club nominated for best
musical or comedy whatever what so it's
like have you listened to his book have
you listened to um what's called a green
light
this guy hey yeah lad starts with a
starts with him on the
the audio book of green light is
incredible because it starts with uh
basically him coming on and i can't do
the voice you can basically just saying
i did this in a weekend
it's fine and everything just starts and
it's amazing
it is
genuinely there are bits where he slips
up there's bits where he just starts
giggling his own joker guys it's the
best audio book i've ever listened to
really
there's also some good kind of folksy
wisdom in there it's quite good that's
how i felt about uh still fooling them
or yeah i think that's what it's called
uh or fooling them maybe just on its own
but it's billy crystal's memoir
essentially and like every other chapter
he reads in front of a live audience
and
i remember he was he went on the daily
this was from like 12 or 13 years ago he
went on the daily show at the time to
promote it and he mentioned that and i i
had never bought audiobooks before was
never i always just bought regular books
but when i heard that i was so intrigued
that i it was back in those days you had
to buy like you know the four-disc
you know thing and put it in the car
please insert disc two to continue the
program
but his book would have been set right
so
it was so beautiful like it's
his stories
about about um
you know muhammad ali and his all of his
experience working as as not you know
not just an actor but but
as a stand-up and like i was blown away
it was and i was never suddenly a billy
crystal fan but i found his story that
book was amazing like i love him he
played a mime and spinal tap like it's
believe me i there's plenty of things
you can love about
his i always liked um i haven't seen it
since it first came out but i remember
liking that what's that movie where the
whole thing is the friends around the
dinner table talking about him and this
other this girl's like love story um
and uh forget paris that's what that's
called
um do you ever see that one yeah but
forget paris is about uh
the whole movie is like them telling
your friends story type oh yeah yeah
like billy crystal know that is in
flashbacks through that movie sure
and uh if i anyway
i said are you done alana because i said
like 15 minutes ago
i have a video game question and you
said let me finish with the
let's get done
okay go ahead
i wanted to add because you said you
were talking about the walking on
eggshells anxiety homelander thing and i
found myself wondering
i can only personally think of one scene
in a game that had that feeling for me
of
life no just
pure simple dialogue being absolutely
unnerving
um
i think the scariest line in any video
game ever that still gives me chills
when i play it is in pt
uh
it the radio says look behind you and
there's nothing behind you but every
time it gives me [ __ ] chills spoiler
i was going to play this afternoon where
you how you can't even download it it's
gone
i think um
hold on we'll understand
which one what wolfenstein i feel like
the new order i found to be pretty
[ __ ] unknown the scene the scene with
hitler
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah venus
um
the way they did that was so unexpected
one of the best scenes i've ever seen in
any video game and it was so
great it was so
[Music]
like disturbed it was the most
emotionally complicated scene because he
was such a like enfiebled busted old man
disgusting
yeah and you have this weird you're like
is this game making me feel bad for
literal hitler uh
yeah it's i bet the meetings where they
would have discussed what they were
going to do with hitler like because
once you have hitler it's so easy to
just make a screaming german but they
that's why
like man in the high castle did a good
job too of like
what happens when hitler gets old and
hitchcock was the one who says the best
villain is one that you can empathize
with
and to make an empathetic that's why
norman bates is one of the best
oh yeah
villains ever because you just feel
sorry for him i was gonna say the same
thing very much with with homelander is
that regardless
you still want him to be your friend
are you done by season three i don't
think what he's saying is
either you don't want him to know that
he that that that you exist or you hope
that you're his friend oh you want to be
on his good side yeah that's what i'm
saying like you you it's it's somehow
it's better to be the devil's pet than
his enemy sure so you'd still want him
to to like you which is a very
complicated
thing
also what was your pick it was that you
mentioned wolfenstein and you grabbed it
it was that that
hitler scene
i know that hitler scene was um
for me i just found myself thinking the
closest analog i can think to those
kinds of homelander moments where you're
just in a scene and it just feels like
it's lit matches and all the or it's
it's unlit matches in all directions and
you're just sitting there playing with
flint you know and you're going this is
going to explode i just that that scene
really
uh because it was
the whole the that whole second game
like new order does that too like new
order has a lot of stuff where um
even after the choice at the very
beginning what's that name for line uh
uh i don't know what actual name is uh
enzo
something like that
ankle ankle i think it might be an ankle
it sounds right yeah uh doctor woman
she's just like you know i've had this
like criticism of a lot of fiction for a
really good books downstairs god damn it
sure it is
end of era
so many
villains in comic books and movies used
to just be hitler they all used to just
be hit but like some just completely
unashamedly they were like just make it
evil well ending bad guy genocide done
unrelatable evil and i think things are
german leather
done they do that a lot too like things
got a lot more nuanced and i feel like
the way wolfenstein tackled the nazi bad
guys was like so uncomfortable
and yeah it's just creepy the way they
use the sexuality for ankle ankle as
well oh just
so unsettling those games are [ __ ]
awesome they really were they ha
spear of destiny
uh and wolfenstein 3d are are among my
very very very first
like
seminal gaming experiences playing
installing off of like 10
floppy disks onto a
uh like ibm 8088 that could barely wait
is that ata
8088
and um
nobody it was i got it i got it i got it
thank you picked up what you put it's a
star wars
i saw this joke i clocked it
just didn't care there you go little
minor quasi redemption
interesting irene engel is the
secondary antagonist of wolfenstein the
new order and the main antagonist of
wolfenstein the new colossus it's weird
i remember her being the main antagonist
of the new order maybe she just stood
out more than i know it's like a bald
guy that you fight in a mech suit
the art direction though that's why i've
got the art books it's just the the way
they
the way they captured that aesthetic and
then carried it forward into like the
60s right the
first one set yeah amazing absolutely
amazing it was yeah it was really and
that was one where
you know
the first one was hardly
aspiring to narrative depth and the fact
that they
re and there have been other sequels
there were there were a few others you
forget how good that first one was like
they do i mean they do it they do it
i've seen they do an auschwitz scene
right in yeah a first person trip that's
bold like oh yeah no one ever did
misguided even like it's like that's in
the very original game oh sorry no i
mean in new orleans you mean back in the
original kind of oh yeah i mean like
that's what i was saying
when they remade it when it was like
getting rebooted or it's actually not a
remake it's technically kind of a sequel
because it takes place after the events
of the original games but after the cast
yeah that that i it's one of those you
just thought you know these were always
just kind of like nazi killing power
fantasy very basic shooters with you
know that were not basic issues
but they were they were
normal in a sense at least narratively
they didn't aspire to anything
i think uh
super
groundbreaking and i i hate to say that
because
for all i know
i mean that's the thing that they're
iconic you know yeah but there's like
everyone hated
[ __ ] romero right after doom came out
because everyone was like well how am i
gonna beat doom and i feel like
wolfenstein is so often just paired as
being like right next to doom because
they were so similar and
well especially watching the beginning
right they've clearly
kind of diverged a little bit more since
definitely completely different now what
doom and wolfenstein are doing couldn't
be more different
and then
i still don't know the context of this
story
mike go watch the offer i'll go watch
the boys alana
you i just watched million dollar baby
and prior to watching it i thought that
it was a movie about like a a baby
version of richie rich
that's did you see the originals
it wasn't the comedy i expected that
it's one of the most depressing films
i've ever seen for no reason it's a baby
worth a million dollars now listen they
don't even say it or reference it
there's no point where they turn cover
and say wow that's what million dollar
payments
baby but how do we get that in the
script
i just thought that movie was so [ __ ]
depressing and i went wow
why is she have to lose her leg as well
why
yeah it just doesn't seem necessary well
one thing
it doesn't and i left me with nothing
other than wow
life's [ __ ] like oh my god
anything like how do we get an oscars
like put her through all of it all of it
and make it real and him too because
every he's blind also every [ __ ] one
of them like it's such it's so obvious
is it a horror movie
is it a horror movie
no i'm gonna go yes
the boys season three this podcast
probably is
uh all right i'm a lot of peace i'm a
video you're right that's rebecca he's a
video game actor that's mike bentley
he's videoing him directly that's
awesome waiting for his video game
proposal thank you for watching please
listen everybody we'll see you next week
bye